.
Dort hinten
sahen wir zuerst nur Rauch.
Plötzlich kam das Feuer über den
Berg und man sah oben alles brennen.
Im August 2021 wüten
auf dem griechischen Peloponnes
schwere Waldbrände.
Auch die Auswanderer aus dem Emmental
sind davon betroffen.
Es kam rasend schnell näher.
Wir waren vom Feuer umzingelt.
Ich dachte: "Jetzt sterbe ich.
Das war's jetzt."
"Nun verbrenne ich mit meinen
Schwiegereltern in diesem Auto."
Drei Wochen vorher
stehen rund ums Haus der Auswanderer
noch Möbel und Zügelkisten.
Alain Aegerter
und Partnerin Anita Thomi
beziehen ihr neues Heim
in der Nähe von Koroni.
Das Bett aufzustellen,
ist das Zeichen,
dass wir wirklich hierbleiben.
Mit dabei: Anitas Schwiegereltern.
Im sonnigen Süden
wollen Anita und Alain
Ferien für Reptilienfreunde anbieten.
Die Einfuhrpapiere für
die Giftschlangen und Schildkröten
fehlen aber.
Die Tiere
bleiben vorerst in der Schweiz.
Wir freuen uns, euch alle
in Schweden zu begrüssen.- Klar.
Jonas und Sabrina Rotzler
aus dem Kanton Solothurn
erhoffen sich
mehr Selbstbestimmung in Schweden.
Mit ihren drei kleinen Kindern
gehen sie auf und davon.
Welcome to Sweden.
- Tack sa mycket.
Eine Ferienanlage mitten im Wald
wollen sie mit neuem Leben füllen.
Nun haben wir drei Wochen Zeit.
Es gibt sehr viel zu tun.
Dann eröffnen wir die Anlage.
Ein luxuriöses Gästehaus
im Osten Kanadas.
Das ist der Traum
von Barbara Hasenböhler
und ihrem Partner Thomas Range.
Hier ist das eine Zimmer.
Hier ist alles offen
und man sieht die ganze Meeresfront.
Sie wollen
zur nächsten Sommersaison eröffnen.
Doch die Baubewilligung
lässt auf sich warten.
Wenn wir im Juli und im August
nicht geöffnet haben,
haben wir ganz klar
ein finanzielles Problem.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Tiefer Winter
auf Prince Edward Island.
Sechs Monate
nach der Ausreise aus der Schweiz.
Einmal mehr
räumt der 47-jährige Thomas
den Zugang zum neuen Heim frei.
Es wird erst dann undankbar,
wenn der Wind nachmittags
aus allen Richtungen kommt
und das ganze Zeug wieder
am selben Ort liegt wie jetzt.
Aber ja.
Ich denke, spätestens übermorgen
beginnt das Ganze von vorn.
Fuck, ist das kalt.
Partnerin Barbara
kümmert sich um den Umbau der Villa.
Nach wochenlanger Verzögerung konnten
die Bauarbeiter endlich starten.
Sieben Gästezimmer sollen entstehen.
Auch die Garage
lassen sie zu Hotelzimmern umbauen.
Nun wird die erste grosse Tür
herausgeschnitten und eingebaut.
Dann sieht man die Grösse
dieses Zimmers und das Meer.
Wo einst
die Autos der Vorbesitzer standen,
sollen bald Feriengäste übernachten.
Nun kriegt das Haus Augen.
Mit den Augen bzw. den Fenstern
kriegt es eine Seele.
* Poltern *
500'000 kanadische Dollar,
umgerechnet gut 370'000 Fr.,
investieren sie allein in den Umbau.
Da wollen die Auswanderer
nichts dem Zufall überlassen.
Schön.
Dafür bezahlen die Leute viel Geld.
Von diesem Fenster aus sieht man
noch diese grotesken Bäume,
an denen der Wind arbeitet.
Das finde ich total interessant.
* Lockere Musik *
Es gibt kaum einen Ort
in der 570 m2 grossen Villa,
der nicht
von den Arbeiten betroffen ist.
Baustaub durchdringt jede Ritze.
Nur die Küche und das Wohnzimmer
bleiben Barbara und Thomas
als Rückzugsort.
Das ist zurzeit das Büro,
unser Wohnbüro.
Dies ist unser Schlaf-Wohnzimmer.
Über drei Monate leben sie schon
zwischen Abdeckfolie und Baumaterial.
Aber es könnte schlimmer sein.
Denn wir haben ein Bett
und es ist warm.
Für den Notfall
hätten wir sogar ein Cheminée.
Wir könnten es
total romantisch gestalten.
Aber das ist der einzige Ort,
den wir abtrennen konnten,
damit wir wenigstens
etwas Privatsphäre haben,
wenn die Jungs
frühmorgens eintreffen.
Momentan ist es einfach, wie es ist.
C'est à prendre ou à laisser.
Fritid: tolv.
Fritid: elva. Fritid ...
30.
Sabrina und Jonas sind mit ihren
drei Kindern heute in der Stadt -
zum ersten Mal.
Eine Dreiviertelstunde Fahrt
mit dem Auto.
Tochter Liana möchte eine Spielküche,
ein verspätetes Geburtstagsgeschenk.
Ja. Oh, schau mal!
Was ist da unten?
Das ist die Küche.
- (Liana) Ich will nicht diese.
* Liana jammert. *
Das war ja klar.
Jetzt gefällt sie ihr nicht.
Was ist nicht in Ordnung?
- Sie will eine pinkfarbene.
Entweder diese oder keine.
- Ich will eine andere.
Entweder jetzt diese
oder irgendwann eine andere.
(Jammernd) Ich will nicht diese.
- Okay, kein Problem. Weiter geht's.
Wo gehst du jetzt hin?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
30.
- Wo ist die 30?
Vorn rechts beim Fenster.
- Dorthin gehe ich.
Der zweijährige Kian
wünscht sich einen Traktor.
Wir schauen uns nochmals die Küchen
an. Liana beruhigte sich etwas.
Hier hast du eine Mikrowelle,
eine Uhr und Knöpfe zum Einschalten.
Willst du sie?
- (Liana) Ja.
Jetzt haben wir's.
* Die Kinder plappern. *
Pst.
Zurück auf der Ferienanlage
Skalsjögarden.
Vor zwei Tagen erst
hat Familie Rotzler den Betrieb
mit 20 Gebäuden übernommen.
Ihr Vorhaben für heute:
im Restaurant aussortieren.
Sabrinas Eltern
sind aus der Schweiz mitgekommen
und wollen ihre Tochter
in den ersten Tagen unterstützen.
Familie Rotzler
hat sämtliches Inventar
von den Vorbesitzern übernommen.
Das war Teil des Deals.
2014 abgelaufen.
* Lachen *
Das ist schon ...
- Die sind jetzt braun.
Thunfisch ...
- Braunzwiebeln.
Im Jahr 2013 abgelaufener Thunfisch.
* Würgegeräusch *
Wir machen einen Wettbewerb:
Wer findet das älteste?
September 2013.
2017.
2011, weg damit.
2021, hey.
Leer. Gut, wenigstens das.
Okay.
Wir wollen irgendwann
ja professioneller kochen,
aber anfangs noch nicht.
Wir haben ja noch nicht viele Gäste.
Wir wollen die Küche
als Küche nutzen.
Das taten
unsere Vorgänger wohl weniger.
Straight.
(Englisch)
Yeah?
- Second door, mid-door.
Nachbar Ulf und Sabrinas Vater Thomas
helfen beim Verstauen des Hausrats,
den Familie Rotzler mitgebracht hat.
Platz dafür hätte es auf der Anlage
eigentlich mehr als genug.
Oh, yeah.
(Jonas, Englisch)
Ein ähnliches Bild
im nächsten Lagerraum.
(Jonas)
Die Nebenräume sind voller Zeug.
Wir können den Betrieb mal aufnehmen
und uns in der Zwischensaison,
wenn wenig los ist,
ums Aufräumen kümmern.
Ich schätze, dass wir
die nächsten zwei bis drei Jahre
mit Aussortieren und Aufräumen
beschäftigt sein werden.
So ist das halt.
In der Gaststube schaut die Mutter
von Sabrina, was noch brauchbar ist.
Es ist extrem viel Arbeit.
Ich würde nicht
mit ihnen tauschen wollen.
Man muss einfach mal
irgendwo anfangen.
Mit der Zeit wird es besser.
Ich finde,
es sieht schon viel besser aus,
wenn nur mal
dieses altbackene Zeug weg ist.
Das hier geht ja noch.
Schau, ich habe dort hinten
aufgeräumt. Wie findest du es?
Hast du das doch gemacht?
- Ja.
Ich wollte noch ...
- Besser und heller.
Nicht wahr? Aber ich finde,
die Lampen müssen weg.
* Düstere Musik *
Drei Wochen nach der Auswanderung
zerstört ein Waldbrand
auf dem südlichen Peloponnes
den Traum von Anita Thomi
und Alain Aegerter.
Ihr eben erst bezogenes Wohnhaus
brennt bis auf die Grundmauern ab.
Vom verheerenden Feuer
hat Alain am Telefon erfahren.
Als es passierte, war er im Emmental.
Er wollte
endlich die Reptilien holen.
Hallo.
Du hast viel Gepäck.
In diesem sind nur Kleider für dich.
- Ja?- Ja.
Darin sind Kleider für mich,
meine Eltern und für dich.
Ja, es brennt überall.
- Sahst du es vom Flugzeug aus?
Ich sah den Rauch dort vorn.
Du warst nicht oben, nicht wahr?
- Nein.
Bei 45 °C Hitze entwickelten sich
in der Region schwere Waldbrände.
Die Feuerwalze zerstörte
mehrere Quadratkilometer
Wald und Olivenhaine -
und das Haus der Emmentaler.
Zum ersten Mal nach dem Feuer
fahren sie zu ihrem Grundstück.
Langsam, bitte.
Ich brauche etwas Zeit.- Ja.
* Anita atmet angespannt aus. *
Das dort unten
gehört auch zu unserem Grundstück.
Dieser traurige, schwarze Klotz
geradeaus ist unser Wassertank.
Alles, was hier verbrannt ist ...
- ... gehört uns.
Die beiden ahnen bereits,
was sie erwartet.
Ein Nachbar war schon am Haus
und hat ihnen Fotos geschickt.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Das Haus haben sie erst vor einem
Jahr für 200'000 Euro gekauft.
Ich bin ehrlich gesagt
etwas sprachlos.
* Düstere Musik *
Das Feuer brach vor vier Tagen aus.
Anita war mit den Schwiegereltern,
die zu Besuch waren, allein im Haus.
Dort hinten
sahen wir zuerst nur Rauch.
Plötzlich kam das Feuer über den
Berg und man sah oben alles brennen.
* Helikopterlärm *
Nach einer bangen Nacht
flüchteten sie zu Hans,
einem befreundeten Nachbarn.
Doch auch von dort mussten sie weg.
Es kam rasend schnell näher.
Ich setzte mich
mit den Schwiegereltern ins Auto
und wir fuhren los.
Doch wir kamen nicht mehr weiter,
weil das Feuer auf der Strasse war.
Hans fuhr voraus
und bog in einen Schotterweg ein.
Wir waren vom Feuer umzingelt.
Ich dachte: "Jetzt sterbe ich.
Das war's jetzt."
"Nun verbrenne ich mit meinen
Schwiegereltern in diesem Auto."
Hans fuhr wie ein Rennfahrer
über die Schotterpiste,
die Steine flogen
und die Flammen kamen immer näher.
Ich dachte nur: "Fahr, fahr, fahr!"
Wir fuhren hinter ihm her
und plötzlich war das Feuer weg.
Hans hat uns das Leben gerettet
und uns in Sicherheit gebracht.
Ja.
Wahnsinn.
Anita ist dankbar,
dass sie unbeschadet
dem Flammenmeer entkommen ist.
Das muss hier ...
Aber finanziell
wird es nun schwierig.
Denn eine Versicherung hatte
das Paar noch nicht abgeschlossen.
Unser Badezimmer.
Wow!
Scheisse.
Fast ihr gesamtes Hab und Gut
ist dem Feuer zum Opfer gefallen.
Ja, unsere Büchersammlung,
all unsere Reptilienbücher.
Die Vitrine deiner Grossmutter, der
Sessel meines Grossvaters ...- Mhm.
Und der schöne Tisch.
- Ja, ja.
Ich trauere allem nach.
Es sind unzählige Dinge.
Ich hatte etliche Bücher
mit Widmungen des Autors.
Diese Autoren
leben teils nicht mehr.
Das ist einfach weg.
Auch die Zeichnungen meines Sohnes
gibt es nicht mehr.
Sie sind hier verbrannt.
* Melancholische Musik *
Hier war das Becken
für die Schnappschildkröten,
das wir schon
teilweise vorbereitet hatten.
Es war schon etwas Wasser drin.
Deswegen wurde das Feuer gestoppt.
Hier schmolz es nur
und dort oben brannte es.
Glück im Unglück: Ihre 65 Reptilien
sind nach wie vor in der Schweiz.
Ich bin extrem froh, dass wir
die Papiere noch nicht hatten.
Das war die Rettung
für all unsere Tiere.
Deshalb sind sie nicht umgekommen.
Ich glaube,
mit dem Tod unserer Tiere
hätte ich
ganz schlecht umgehen können.
Das wäre für mich das Schlimmste
und Traurigste gewesen,
das hätte passieren können.
Ja.
Wie durch ein Wunder
wurden auch die Werkstatt
und das bereits errichtete
Schildkrötenhaus vom Feuer verschont.
(Mann) Ich wollte mir
den Transformator anschauen.
Er ist nicht verbrannt, oder?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Aber das Kabel sieht scheisse aus.
- Ja.
Makler Georgios ist vorbeigekommen.
Er will sehen,
wie es den Schweizern geht.
Gott sei Dank starb niemand
und es wurde niemand verletzt.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Häuser kann man wiederaufbauen.
Zudem übernimmt der
griechische Staat 80 % der Kosten,
um ein neues Haus zu bauen.
Das glaube ich erst, wenn es klappt.
Aber es klingt
natürlich interessant.
Doch, das stimmt.
- Ich glaube es dir.
Das sagte
der Präsident höchstpersönlich.
Als es mal kleine Brände
in Olivenhainen usw. gab,
wurde immer bezahlt.
Wir hoffen,
dass alles wieder gut wird.
* Melancholische Musik *
Trotz eisiger Temperaturen:
Auf der Baustelle in Kanada haben die
Handwerker alle Hände voll zu tun.
Auch Auswanderin Barbara
ist von früh bis spät beschäftigt.
(Handwerker)
(Anita)
Yeah, good, good.
Die 45-jährige Barbara sorgt dafür,
dass der Bau vorangeht
und dass es den Handwerkern
an nichts fehlt.
Ich finde, wenn sie schon drinnen
und draussen arbeiten müssen -
auf unserer Baustelle
ist es ja nicht gerade warm ...
... ist es nicht mehr als recht,
ihnen eine warme Mahlzeit
aufzutischen.
Da ich extra etwas für sie tue,
tun sie auch extra etwas für mich.
Es ist ein Geben und Nehmen.
Die Muffins sind schon bereit
und der Kaffee auch.
Aber erst um 10 Uhr, nicht wahr?
- Ja, ja.
So wie immer.
* Hämmern *
* Läuten der Glocke *
Thomas ist heute zu Hause.
Vier Tage in der Woche
arbeitet der gelernte Hotelfachmann
in einem Café in
der Provinzhauptstadt Charlottetown.
Morning.
# Ta-da-da.
So, ich glaube, das war's schon.
Die Wohnküche ist nicht nur während
der Bauzeit das Herzstück des Hauses.
Ab der Eröffnung im Sommer
will Barbara hier
ihre zahlenden Gäste bekochen.
(Anita)
Dreimal pro Tag verwöhnt
Hobbyköchin Barbara die Handwerker
mit selbst gemachten Köstlichkeiten.
(Anita)
* Lockere Musik *
Der Winter auf Prince Edward Island
ist hart.
Eisige Winde und Temperaturen
weit unter dem Gefrierpunkt
sind keine Seltenheit.
Dazu gibt es immer wieder
Eisregen und Schneestürme.
So. Wie viel haben wir
diesen Monat für Saft ausgegeben?
Die Heizölrechnung?
- Ja, Heizöl.
Hm!
So viel war es noch nie.
- Oh!
Ist das die Monatsrechnung?
- Mhm.
* Anita lacht. *
Sie ist vierstellig?
- Ja.
Ach, herrje.
Es ist einfach zum Schreien.
Manchmal herrschten bis zu -20 °C
und der Wind wehte mit 40-50 km/h.
Wir gaben 2'000 Dollar
für Heizöl aus -
pro Monat.
Wir sprechen nicht
von einer Jahresrechnung.
Wir budgetierten es, aber es nervt.
Wir haben auch
eine extrem hohe Stromrechnung,
wegen der Heizkörper, damit
die Handwerker nicht erfrieren.
Unsere utility bills -
Heizung, Strom usw. -
sind zurzeit unglaublich hoch.
Wenn das so weitergeht, müssen sie
ihr Budget für den Umbau aufstocken.
Rufst du uns mal an?
Abgemacht? Nein? Rufst du nicht an?
Dann bin ich aber traurig.
Johnny, tschüss. Mach's gut.
Tschau, vielen Dank.
Haltet die Ohren steif
und arbeitet nicht allzu viel.
Bei Familie Rotzler in Schweden
heisst es Abschied nehmen.
Sabrinas Eltern
fahren zurück in die Schweiz.
Meldet euch von unterwegs.
Mhm.
- Und danke für eure Hilfe.
Tschüss, mach's gut. Küsschen?
Sagst du mir Tschüss?
Tschüss.
- (Kind) Nochmals tschüss.
Danke schön.
- Danke, gute Fahrt.
Gleich danach hat sich Jonas
mit dem Vorbesitzer verabredet.
(Ake, Englisch)
Ake soll Jonas
die Holzschnitzelheizung erklären.
(Ake)
Die Heizungsanlage
muss Jonas künftig selber warten.
(Englisch)
Ich habe noch mehr Autos gefunden.
Unterdessen versucht Sabrina,
Ordnung ins Kistenchaos zu bringen.
Hier.
Das kleine Gästehaus
gegenüber dem Restaurant
hat Familie Rotzler
als neues Zuhause ausgewählt.
* Weinen *
Jonas und Sabrina
sind nun doppelt gefordert:
Sie müssen die Familie managen
und auch das Geschäft mit
der Ferienanlage zum Laufen bringen.
Schon in drei Wochen
haben sie erste Buchungen.
Dabei sind sie auf die Unterstützung
der Vorbesitzer angewiesen.
Das grösste Problem ist das - so
nenne ich es mal - Missverständnis,
dass es bisher immer hiess,
dass es kein Problem sei,
die Anlage per 1. Juli zu eröffnen.
Für die Alkohol-
und Restaurationslizenz
würde sich eine Lösung finden.
Das ist nun plötzlich
nicht mehr so selbstverständlich.
Das Geld ist geflossen,
es befindet sich nun bei ihnen,
und die Motivation,
dass die Lizenzen bestehen bleiben,
ist etwas kleiner geworden.
Ihrer Meinung nach können wir die
Lizenz ohne PN gar nicht erwerben.
Das dauert vier bis sechs Wochen.
Man rechne.
Im schlimmsten Fall können wir den
Gästen keinen Alkohol ausschenken.
Dann müssen sie
ihren Alkohol selbst mitbringen.
Das ist der Worst Case -
bis jetzt.
Vielleicht kommt ja noch mehr.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Jonas kann nur hoffen, dass er
mit seinen Bedenken falsch liegt.
Hallo.
- (Sabrina) Hej.
Auf ihn hingegen ist Verlass: Nachbar
Ulf hat Farbmuster organisiert.
Sabrina und Jonas
wollen die Gasträume im Restaurant
neu streichen.
Ein Freund von Ulf
arbeitet mit Farben,
und ein anderer Freund von ihm
arbeitet mit Bodenbelägen.
Das ist cool. Er organisierte das
ganz kurzfristig für uns.
Es ist toll, wenn man
solche Unterstützung erhält.
Und das ist noch nicht alles.
Als Nächstes fährt er Jonas
zu einem Besichtigungstermin.
Bisher verging kein Tag, ohne dass
er seine Hilfe angeboten hätte.
(Ulf)
* Lachen *
Jonas möchte ein gebrauchtes
Geländefahrzeug kaufen.
Das Quad hat Ulf im Internet entdeckt
und gleich auch
den Besichtigungstermin vereinbart.
(Ulf)
(Jonas)
Jonas möchte das Quad,
um sich auf seinem grossen Grundstück
schneller fortzubewegen.
(Jonas)
(Ulf)
(Ulf, Schwedisch)
(Jonas)
(Verkäufer, Schwedisch)
60'000.
- Yeah.
60'000 Kronen muss Jonas bezahlen,
umgerechnet 5'500 Fr.
Ulf schiesst Jonas das Geld vor.
In Schweden
gibt es eine Zahlungs-App,
die alle für Zahlungen benutzen.
Wir können sie noch nicht verwenden,
weil man dafür
eine Personennummer braucht.
Ulf wickelt die Zahlung
nun für uns ab.
Wir sind total froh,
dass er uns hilft.
(Jonas)
* Ulf lacht. *
(Ulf)
Auch in Kanada spielen Fahrzeuge
im neuen Leben der Auswanderer
eine wichtige Rolle.
Schneeverwehungen versperren
die Parkplätze der Handwerker.
Grundsätzlich ist das
eine lustige Geschichte.
Ich würde es nicht täglich und nicht
12 Std. am Stück machen wollen,
aber eine Fahrt ist okay.
Zudem ist es heute
ja wirklich überschaubar.
In 20-30 Min. ist das
mehr oder weniger erledigt.
Die Arbeit mit der schweren Maschine
ist für Thomas
eine willkommene Abwechslung.
* Lockere Musik *
Barbara hingegen freut sich über die
Ankunft eines langersehnten Pakets.
Schau, Hase,
welchen findest du besser?
Keine Ahnung.
Sie hat Teppiche bestellt.
Das sind
zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Ja, aber
das Grundmaterial ist dasselbe:
Jute und recycled Jeans.
Das ist der Grosse.
Ich glaube,
der war fürs Wohnzimmer gedacht.
Aber vielleicht platziere ich ihn
auch im Spitzgiebelzimmer, Suite 8.
Also, mit den richtigen Möbeln
und so ...
Wir haben ja Leinenmöbel.
- ... sieht das sicher schön aus.
Es passt sicher
nicht überallhin, aber ...
Für ihr Gästehaus stimmen die beiden
jedes Detail aufeinander ab.
Wir haben schon damit angefangen,
Dinge zu sammeln.
Das hier werden mit
einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von 99,9 %
unsere Teller sein.
Ich könnte mir z.B. vorstellen,
eine grüne Serviette ...
... auf dem Teller zu platzieren.
Ganz natürlich.
Ihr Konzept für das Gästehaus
scheint anzukommen.
Denn obwohl
noch kein einziges Zimmer fertig ist,
haben sie bereits mehrere Buchungen.
Zwei bis drei Zimmer
werden auf jeden Fall fertig sein.
Zwei bis drei weitere Zimmer
könnten wir notfalls auch mit
unseren eigenen Möbeln möblieren.
Für den Fall, dass die Möbel-
lieferung zu spät kommt, weil ...
... Covid wieder zuschlägt
oder was weiss ich.
Die Buchungen machen Mut.
Trotzdem wird das Geld
für den Umbau immer knapper.
Es wird nicht leichter by the way.
* Anita lacht. *
Durch die Pandemie sind auch
die Materialkosten massiv gestiegen.
Siehst du, nun kann ich es
selbst umfüllen, Schatz.
Klar, ich sagte ja nicht,
dass es unnötig oder unüberlegt ist.
Die eigenen vier Wände
will Barbara selber streichen.
Schon bei ihrer Eigentumswohnung
in Glattfelden war es v.a. Barbara,
die Hand anlegte.
Die Gästezimmer streiche ich nicht.
Für die Gäste
muss alles perfekt sein.
Aber hier möchte ich das machen.
Dann kann ich sagen,
dass ich das selbst gemacht habe.
Ich fühle mich da nicht so ...
Nicht, dass ich dazu nicht in der
Lage wäre, aber ich bin einfach ...
Thomas hasst es,
sich die Hände schmutzig zu machen.
Ich liebe es,
mir die Hände schmutzig zu machen.
Dann sieht man,
dass man etwas geleistet hat.
Schön, eine arbeitet
und der andere spielt.
Ja, es hat halt jeder seine Stärken.
Nun kommst du auch noch, Gini.
So unterschiedlich sie auch sind -
das gemeinsame Ziel
verlieren sie nicht aus den Augen.
Zehn Autominuten
von der Ruine ihres Hauses entfernt
haben die Emmentaler
vorübergehend Unterschlupf gefunden.
Zwei Studios hat ihnen ein Bekannter
kostenlos zur Verfügung gestellt.
Erstmals können sie
etwas zur Ruhe kommen.
Denn der Schock der Erlebnisse
sitzt bei Anita und ihren
Schwiegereltern immer noch tief.
Wir haben Glück,
dass wir überlebt haben.
Wer das noch nie erlebt hat,
kann sich das gar nicht vorstellen.
Es war eine Katastrophe.
Das Feuer war auf der Strasse,
auf der wir hätten fahren müssen.
Und dann ...
- Es ging rasend schnell.
Ich dachte,
wir kämen nicht mehr durch.- Mhm.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Auf der Flucht vor den Flammen
konnte Anita kaum etwas mitnehmen.
Er ist schwer, was?
- Ja.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Ich hätte noch 100 g Reserve gehabt.
Das ist alles,
was ich an Kleidern noch habe.
Ein Rock,
ein T-Shirt,
ein Leibchen, zwei kurze Hosen,
ein Bikini,
irgendwo hängt noch ein Badeanzug
und das, was ich trage.
Und diese Schuhe.
Das ist knapp die Hälfte.
- Knapp die Hälfte?- Ja.
Zwei Koffer voller Kleider hat
Alain aus der Schweiz mitgebracht.
Eine Freundin hat sie in einer
Blitzsammelaktion zusammengetragen.
Oh, Turnschuhe.
Das ist ja cool.
Oh, Schlangenhosen.
Schlangenhosen besass ich noch nie.
Ich dachte:
"Die muss ich einpacken."
"Little dreams
can become big adventures".
Ja, tatsächlich.
Total schöne Sachen.
Trotz der Tragödie:
Anita versucht, ihr Schicksal
anzunehmen und nach vorn zu schauen.
Das Leben ist das Wichtigste.
Es kam niemand zu Schaden.
Die grösste Tragödie wäre gewesen,
wenn ich überlebt hätte,
aber meine Schwiegereltern
nicht hätte retten können.
Für mich steht fest,
dass ich hierbleibe.
Ich habe wirklich das Gefühl,
hier zu Hause zu sein.
Das ist mein Lieblingsschnitt.
Es ist etwas elastisch.
Zumindest Anita
will an ihrem Traum festhalten.
Ich habe mir noch nicht
so viele Gedanken gemacht.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich kann es noch nicht sagen.
Ich habe zwiespältige Gefühle.
Hierbleiben oder zurückgehen?
Diese Frage müssen die beiden
jetzt miteinander klären.
Ganz andere Probleme
haben die Auswanderer in Kanada.
Barbara und Thomas
haben zwar genau kalkuliert,
doch was sie nicht ahnen konnten:
Die Kosten für Baumaterial
und Energie steigen immer weiter.
Jetzt müssen sie
mehr Geld auftreiben.
Sonst können sie
den Umbau nicht fertigstellen.
(Mann) Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Es gibt Finanzierungsangebote.
Genügend.- Eine 100-%-Finanzierung
ist bei ihnen kein Thema.
Barbara hat einen Makler kontaktiert.
Sie wollen
ihre Eigentumswohnung in Glattfelden,
die sie bisher behalten haben,
verkaufen.
Auf jeden Fall.
- Perfekt. Super, danke.
Einen schönen Tag.
- Danke, auf Wiederhören.
So, wir haben
einen Schlachtplan erstellt.
Wir diskutierten über die Optionen,
die wir haben:
uns von der Bank Geld leihen,
eine Tante oder einen Onkel fragen
oder was einem
sonst noch einfallen könnte.
Wir kamen relativ rasch auf Idee,
unsere Wohnung zu verkaufen.
So können wir freiwerdende
Liquidität hier sinnvoll einsetzen.
Unser Zuhause ist hier
oder anderswo in der Schweiz,
aber nicht mehr in Glattfelden.
Dieses Kapitel
haben wir abgeschlossen.
Mit der jetzigen Lösung
geben wir unser eigenes Geld aus.
Wir müssen nicht
irgendjemanden um Geld bitten.
Das ist ein gutes Gefühl.
* Bellen *
Geh zu Papa.
Du kannst sie gleich
in die Tasche stecken.
Wenn jetzt
nichts Unerwartetes mehr passiert,
sollten sie
den Umbau ihres Gästehauses
planmässig abschliessen können.
* Bellen *
* Verträumte Musik *
Noch ist die Ferienanlage
von Familie Rotzler geschlossen.
Aber schon in drei Wochen
haben Sabrina und Jonas erste Gäste.
Vier Männer aus Stockholm haben
bei ihnen ein Wochenende gebucht -
mit Halbpension.
Doch welche der vielen Zimmer
sollen sie für die Gäste herrichten?
Hier gibt es
eine Toilette und eine Dusche.
Das ist ein süsses Zimmer.
Mhm.
Lüften muss man überall.
- Lüften ist nicht das Problem.
Die Tapete ist cool.
Ja, und hier
ist ein lustiger Sessel.
Welcher Sessel?
- Dieser schöne Sessel.
Der wunderschöne Sessel.
- Das sind zwei schöne Zimmer.
Für den Anfang wollen sie die Zimmer
noch so lassen, wie sie sind,
später dann nach und nach renovieren.
Das hier muss man wie all diese
Bereiche mal gründlich reinigen.
Der Ablauf stinkt.
Das ist das Thema mit den Abläufen.
Wenn sie mal sauber sind,
ist es wieder gut.
Schatz,
was ist das hier in der Ecke?
Ah, jetzt weiss ich,
weshalb es so stank.
Geh kurz weg, Schatz.
Geh weg, Schatz.
- Ich bin weg.
Sie fürchtet sich extrem vor Nagern.
Es roch irgendwie nach Verwesung.
Dieses Tierchen kam von hier.
Ja.
Es kam aus dem Abfluss.
* Er lacht humorlos. *
War hier ein Tierchen?
- Ja.
Das ist ein lustiges Tier,
das ich noch nicht kenne.
Pfui. Das ist irgendeine ...
... seltsame Ratte.
Interessant.
Diese Viecher kenne ich nicht.
Irgendeine Pelzratte.
Können wir die Zimmer
wohl in drei Wochen vermieten?
Wir müssen einfach
die Schädlinge bekämpfen.
Wo entsorgst du es jetzt?
Ja, was soll ich damit machen?
Irgendwo,
wo es der Hund nicht kriegt.
Für Jonas ist klar,
er muss so schnell wie möglich
den Kammerjäger kontaktieren.
* Motorsäge *
Himmelherrgott noch mal!
Anita, wo bist du?
Ich brauche dich. Man kann sie
nur mit drei Händen starten.
Alain hat sich von einem Nachbarn
eine Motorsäge geliehen.
Seine eigene ist verbrannt.
Er will die verkohlten Bäume
auf dem Grundstück entfernen.
Zu gross ist die Gefahr,
dass sie sich noch einmal entzünden.
Dass wir hier aufräumen,
liegt daran,
dass wir uns heute zusammengesetzt
und eine Grundsatzentscheidung
gefällt haben.
Für uns ist es klar -
für mich etwas klarer -
dass wir hierbleiben
und alles wieder aufbauen wollen.
Und die Zeichen für den Neuanfang
stehen offenbar gut.
Am Strommast
hängt bereits ein neuer Trafo.
Makler Georgios hat den Austausch
für die Schweizer organisiert.
Es ist wunderbar, wenn ein Trafo in
so kurzer Zeit ausgewechselt wird.
Dabei hatten wir nur mal kurz
mit jemandem darüber diskutiert.
In der Schweiz
besteht auch Diskussionsbedarf,
wenn an einem Strommast
etwas repariert werden muss.
Das läuft super hier.
Jetzt will Alain sehen, ob auf
den Leitungen auch schon Strom ist.
So, jetzt ist er geöffnet.
Ja, los, drücken.
Komm.
- Es gibt einen Knall.
Gut, aufhören. Super.
Super, d.h., dass Spannung ankommt.
Wenn wir Spannung haben,
können wir Wasser hierherpumpen.
Noch aber scheint es
einen Kurzschluss zu geben.
Dieses Kabel kommt von dort
und geht hier runter.
Hier ist der Hauptschalter.
Meine Güte.
Der, der das installiert hat,
war eine Pfeife.
Ich bin froh,
dass ich mir keinen Schreiner,
sondern einen Elektriker angelte.
Ja, so ist es gut. Wir haben Strom.
So, geschlossen.
Der erste Schritt zur Rückkehr
ist gemacht.
Aber wie lange wird es dauern, bis
die beiden hier wieder wohnen können?
(Mann) Jonas, a guest is here.
In der nächsten Folge
begrüsst Familie Rotzler in Schweden
ihre ersten zahlenden Gäste.
Welches Gemüse soll ich kochen?
- Ähm ...
Tomaten, Zucchetti, Peperoni ...
Meine Güte, diese Messer.
Gerade halten.
Eine Belastungsprobe
für die junge Familie.
Smaklig maltid.
In Griechenland sind Alain und Anita
endlich wieder komplett.
Es ist super, dass es endlich
klappte und sie nun hier sind.
Aber jetzt brauchen sie alle Kraft
für den Wiederaufbau
ihres Wohnhauses.
Juhu!
Und:
Eine böse Überraschung in Kanada.
Ça marche, ça marche.
Barbara bricht sich wenige Wochen
vor der Eröffnung den Knöchel.
Ich wurde operiert und
nun sind Platten und Schrauben drin.
Thomas muss
die Baustelle nun allein managen.
Ich bin nicht happy
mit der Situation.
# U sie stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nüm meh hei.
# U sie löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neus Dahei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo, yeah.